their faces are worn with tiredness but
these are the men slowly claiming back
Ukrainian territory on the Eastern front
and they can smell victory
right now they're full of confidence and
bravado
and they're bursting to retake more
how confident are you about retaking
several of the next Lizzy Shanks
100 he says this is Ukraine
this is their biggest win on the
battlefield in weeks and the first since
Vladimir Putin declared this Russian
territory so tearing down the Russian
Flags inside Lehman is delivered with
particular relish
seizing Lehman its hoped will be the
Launchpad to reclaim even more land in
the east
and with the first Ukrainian celebrating
with their foreign friends who'd fought
alongside them
now they're pushing forward the road to
Lehman is littered with the discards of
fierce fighting but the ukrainians say
they've also surrounded their enemy in
parts of lissy Shanks nearly 60
kilometers away
neighboring towns like service have
suffered badly in the fight to retake
Lehman with house after house destroyed
those still here are just clinging to
Hope
I want a piece I want that my parents
will be alive I want that my wife a real
life nothing more
but Russians are still close enough to
instill much fear
that seems to be getting closer and
closer and they may be going backwards
but they're still hammering as much as
they can and this area is already taken
a huge amount of
hammering already
40 minutes south the ferocity of the
Russian assault is Stark in Buck moot
this was the ukrainian's key military
hub for the East now blasted to bits and
a virtual Ghost Town
there are enormous craters which have
utterly changed the geography around
here and ripped the heart out of the
town
the holdouts move around in a war-torn
haze weary and tearful
it's for those who divide you they
divide big money between them and they
don't care about us people the people
who are living here
sorry because a lot of my friends died
big politics is filthy she says
Victory tastes very different depending
on where you are
and the Russians are still on the edges
of bakmud fighting
[Music]
and making their presence very much felt
did you think the Russians were did they
come close to coming in
you understand maybe for a little while
they will succeed but everyone wants the
opposite
but here there's a lot of collaborators
a lot and they're saying a lot of
terrible things
yeah I start arguing with them which I
shouldn't do because God forbid if they
do come here those people will be the
first to
betray
Ed the ukrainians are hoping the Battle
of Lehman may prove a turning point in
this war but so many and so much has
been sacrificed already
Alex Crawford Sky News in eastern
Ukraine